[Musik]
da sich zu - auf ihrem weg zur
diplomatie statt eigentlich kraus
station auf dem programm steht seit sie
ihres ausland praktikum machen aber sind
das hat aber noch einige anträge gar
nichts sagen und ich verschossen hatte
seine abo einfach
und wie nie bin ich so froh danke aber
jetzt ohnehin das wird nicht einfach
kind und karriere als kombinierer aber
zamira das unbedingt schaffen
[Musik]
er ist der sekte zettel auch deutsche
diplomatie ist in der schweiz nicht
besonders beliebt man kennt es wenn das
ist viel ich glaube ich schon auf sie
zählen wir für die nächsten jahrzehnte
[Musik]
das extrem internationale stimmigen hat
blüte ganze war es sind viele
internationale organisationen vor ort
und mir kommt das so
zum gong diplomatique zu der 2 jährige
diplomat aus billig von alexander
kerschakow six kampf mit gott zum ganz
besonderen auftrag
nachdem uns dahingehend kollege dustin
anbieter
lift mit start denn er macht das werk
lepanto zweitkarte zwar nach rom zwei
liegt
ein zweiter stock
[Musik]
security sicherheit von prinz hat das
gewünscht prozent der bürger dass das
sei alles reibungslos abläuft
ganz konnte grad
deutsche post die prinzen als
vorsitzende vom un gremium für wasser
ein vortrag zu dem thema halten
aufgabe von alexander ist es der
hochrangig organisch wasserexperte
sinnvoll und sicher und pünktlich zwei
stücke für die konferenz begleitet
[Musik]
oliver prinz aber da ich irgendwie
verschwunden
sehr lange lift fort
sind laut bäte während er versprach sie
kam mit dem hilft russische kurzen ja
es gebe interessante meinte liebsch und
eigentlich unter den sind inzwischen
forscher stoppt sie ins programm
geschafft mit seinem vortrag über die
politische bedeutung von ascot prinz
hassan pünktlich starten
[Musik]
wir nach der für ihre heißt führt
christina zieht im unteren gardinen zu
verbringen
zweimal mit ihrer zwillingsschwester
francesco von christina wichtige
bezugsperson ist als zwillingsschwester
die zwei aber nicht immer so einfach
[Musik]
mit dem seminar wird bewusst dass es
mathematisch naturwissenschaftlichen
gymnasium und david bach gymnasium und
sehr wirklich bewusst ausgewählt dort
zwei verschiedene typen
die festliche dekoration ist fachgebiet
wurde mamma wellness
der corriere garten doch nicht ganz ohne
diskutieren
die der familie wären es stimmt bis ins
kleinste detail und die nächste
generation ist schon in der sportlichen
christine tante vor der kleinen leonie
[Musik]
die ganz familie sehr stolz ruft aus
christina es bildet so diplomatie machen
ihr vater weiß genau wo sie die tochter
das hat der staat will die
leistungsbereitschaft
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
christina bald muss lehrer ist ob china
das kürzel diplomatin aber dazu sobald
kurz vor 15 uhr auf new york für die
praktische politik
[Musik]
mit gott und königsdisziplin diplomatie
die junge die promoter lernt wie man
verhandelt frauen für jonas ein
wichtiges aus studierte physikerin
exotin diplomatische geschafft aber es
gibt doch eine da ist er bei wickie
jonas naturwissenschaftler
der ehemalige spitzendiplomat michael
ambühl die vertraue darauf dass wir
jetzt hier unter uns sind und dass wir
da auch eben hier eine gewisse
vertraulichkeit legen können
kommt der schweizer finanzplatz
international unter beschuss ist er
gefordert die wunderwaffe mister
steuerdeal oder pokerface der diplomatie
hat michael ambühl seine karriere
verschrieben der aufstieg verlief steil
er gehörte zur delegation die für die
schweiz die bilateralen abkommen mit der
eu aushandeln
gute dienste gibt es zweierlei kategorie
meine chef findet ja frau kam innehat
müsse an brühl und netbooks sehr viel
kaffee und das habe ich mich sehr gut
gemerkt dass eine schöne formulierung er
hat jetzt hier nur sehr wirtschaft hat
dann aber trotzdem eigentlich
unverdiente weise finde ich auf ein
solches plastisches bild hat es gebracht
aber was sie beachten müssen ist eben
die kenntnisse in einzelnen dossiers
sagte nissen
und dann die fähigkeit haben das zu
generalisieren auf politischer ebene zu
heben
wieviel pause bis zum hobby länger habe
also 10 32 ich habe sehr großen respekt
vor ihm und es ist großes privileg das
wäre zwar immer dort verlieren als einer
der besten verhandler patricia hexe
jetzt gibt sicherheit für jonas sich
akustische mit dem vorbild seiner
komplexität einigem aus der darstellung
und hat mir schon recht und als
grundlage
aber da kann man theoretisch modifiziert
die formel von der grundlegenden
moralphilosophie wahl und das sozusagen
eine alternative theorie in formulieren
harnsäure aktion ist das natürlich
extrem spannend so sehr wie die
verhandlungsmacht display gleitet und
versuche ich züchten sollen
und wieder einmal sehr faszinieren
gefunden aber selber der heranbildung
für den zugang zur diplomatie hat und
die inspiration für mich
für händler mit schweizer diplomatinnen
und diplomaten zu können
dieses land zum beispiel die der eu es
braucht vielmehr vertrag und roma
vielmehr verhandlungen
[Musik]
als amiri uno konferenz
sie hat sich eines recht komplexes thema
müsse lasse es geht um autonomie
waffensystem muss sie die
unterschiedlichen positionen der pflicht
zum tragen
ein arbeitskollege fotos an jeder star
zum sie unterstützen falls die frage hat
zum inhalt oder zum ablauf vor der
konferenz
international hier am genfer uno sitz
diskutieren regierungsexperten noch bis
freitag über den umgang mit autonomen
waffensystemen hier hat kein soldat mehr
den finger am abzug waffensysteme wie
dieses beschäftigen die
staatengemeinschaft autonome
waffensysteme wir wollen dass die messe
präsident
jetzt im saal ist eine ausbildungs hause
wir zeigen dir jetzt wie das mit der
konstanz funktionieren der verständnis
zurückgekauft und nachsucht deutliche
positionen umsetzen weiter weil die
stadt das sorgt vor der autobahnauffahrt
staat aber differenziert die position ja
eigentlich auch liv tyler bei dem
schädiger in dem schwenninger campus was
wird es der pause führt samir option das
wichtig ist aber dass er sich auf mich
los darüber bringen
da wird einem ja aber das ist klar mehr
druck machen alles was gemacht wird
beurteilt und ist wichtig wenn es am
schluss darum geht die diplomatische
ausbildet gestorben
[Musik]
das bedeutet für die jonas heimat
[Gelächter]
immer wieder fordert diplomaten
botschaft in berlin aber auf seine
partnerin nicht so einfach
[Musik]
das ist nicht einfach der kurzen zeit
geschafft
das erkennt dass ich wirklich ich kann
noch nicht so wirklich spanisch also ich
kann nur auf englisch meine unterricht
anbieten und über konzerte das geht
immer also musik kann man spielen aber
auch die verbindungen also die kontakte
auch zu knüpfen dauer zeit
[Musik]
das ist eine entscheidung von lebensform
ich habe sie nicht dass es anders als
wenn man jährigen darsteller nimmt um so
gesagt jetzt mach ich das einmal
parierte besonders da sich ihre
lebensform für die man sich entscheidet
und wo über die ganze familie bezieht
was sie seien für die große vorträge
[Musik]
also heute einige careys ausklang
jean baptiste kantonsschule mit dem
schüler und im showroom begründet spürt
trends namens opera house louis in
fribourg gründet christina könnte jean
baptist von dem frühen schock weil ich
kein gas gab runde leader schaftliche
hoch ich muss ein bisschen fokus auf die
auf diese auf diese speise liste
[Gelächter]
es ist ja schon zurzeit dann verliere
ich vielleicht habe ich den controller
die operation dann kritisch das ist wenn
ich die nicht in der regierung und
nehmen sie immer schwächer und du hast
die bereich wo ja da bin ich mir königs
bereich und damit das lieber keine hilfe
will chemie routine sozusagen gestört
oder sogar stimmt
freundschaft regelmäßig flackert dass
ich mit ihm internationale diplomaten
aber sehr schwierig
[Musik]
mittels sehr interessieren
ja und dass das ist das ist natürlich
ein sich einen vorteil ich den beruf das
ist es wirklich sehr sympathisch macht
gern aufmerksamkeit natur schon verblüht
ja nicht gesagt dass das werk mehrheit
ist nicht so wie er das ist klar
umso besser nicht wo haben sie eine
persönlichkeit wie sowas ist gewählt ja
ja schon sehr traurig dass er geht
ich möchte viele leute noch sehen ich
treffe mich jedem wochenende mit familie
nicht verhindern aber noch werden
volldampf volle pulle und dann
irgendwann kommt vielleicht reality
check
bald wird jean baptiste westafrika in
senegal reise aber vorher verabschiedete
sich auf was in ihrer heimatstadt
freiburg das eistraining also richtig
losging dann verlasse ich meine umgebung
meine komfortzone verlassen
die freundinnen die familie freunden
friso und ja es ist ein mich gefühlt
aber ich liebe das man aus reis desto
mehr braucht man so einfach wo man sich
wohlfühlt so zu hause so heimat ist für
mich ist geboren
wieso ist ein wichtiger teil davon
[Musik]
alexander verabschiedet sich für sie in
der familie
das klima am besten
die sagen haben wird dass im
jahresschnitt schlacht naja jetzt lustig
einmal einleben zu machen
sachsens
irgendwo ankommen
stress
für alexander fort jetzt ein neuer
lebensabschnitt sein erster job als
diplomaten im ausland
[Musik]
das ist doch wie ist die häufigste 15
sammler box profi
kürzere das master das ganze schneller
der rechtsruck nach werk
mit mit dem möbeltransport
[Musik]
danke
umfrage im handwerk sieht auch die
ordner sortiert und vom militär regiert
wird 350 millionen menschen
das bedeutet die freiheit viele chancen
aber auch großer softie und
wirtschaftliche probleme
[Musik]
danke danke
überhaupt klasse dass man das macht
die botschaft sagt ja alles bestens noch
stand dafür 12 stunden schlafe darum
wieder topfit
thema war groß im schwange ist das
boomende demokratisch und für alles gut
machen und dass das wort für tourismus
saldo unter der militärdiktatur
das war aus benutzt hat ist in christo
also man muss sehen was das land für
mitgemacht hat in verhältnismäßig guter
teams der alexander willer 73 ein gutes
druckmittel oder wir sehr oft immer
namens alexander hat er in seinem
originale filmmusik von der german
speakers witze sind der neue titel sind
[Gelächter]
noch meeting gott für den nachwuchs
diplomat weiter direkt vorgesetzte erste
aufgabe und danke
geht ihr das so yang gon
also hier habe ich für dich zum einlesen
da noch die hintergrundinformationen
sind dokument das die botschaft immer
macht die politische synthese wenn du
siehst dass da etwas noch verärgert ist
dass man aktualisieren sollte die
vorbereitung ist ganz ganz wichtig
[Musik]
das hat doch mit einer persönlichen
stolz sind
man hat die chance jetzt zwei jahre
nichts machen und wir haben in vietnam
überbringen dass mir dass man das ist
ein guter grund gibt warum oskar
antworten ist und ja es gab vielleicht
auch ein spitzenresultat bewiesen dass
das ist dass es praktisch dass man
erwarte nicht
wird schweiz im ausland wird radbruch
der starke wille und figur der alles
anders
[Musik]
kenne ich nicht sehen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
jean baptist startet viel gemütlicher
den 10er stock geschlafen
ob super gut geschlafen endlich hatte
ich habe ich seinerzeit das ist unser
schoss stefan
wenn du für die erste mal in einer stadt
gegend wo auf der welt ist das erste
taxi oder bus fährt bis zum hauptteil
oder wieso irgendwo dass das finde ich
super
für die nächsten 5 10 15 20 und der
vorzeige demokratie auf dem
afrikanischen kontinent
bald trifft es jean baptist cdu chefin
nur wenn es sich auch bezüge wird es mit
dem diplomatenstatus
gespannt
und das ist sie botschafterin marion
weichelt also ich lass dich bei normalen
und wichtig dass so ein sitzungsraum in
freier luft ja sehr schön
[Musik]
als diplomat ist daher muss der jean
baptiste panikzentrale berichte wie die
politische situation vor ort ist nur
über senegal nachbarländer wie mali oder
die nähe des hauptthemas strasser
situation im land und
präsidentschaftswahlen im nächsten jahr
darf ich natürlich ein bisschen platz
aber kennen gelernt ja fast alle alle
die da sie in mindestens mit sie genau
mir ist es sehr wichtig dass immer eine
kurze notiz gemacht werden selbst wenn
nur darin steht ich habe dann und dann
die und die person getroffen und über
1000 ausgesprochen und zwar im sinne der
nachvollziehbarkeit des taxis also ich
sehe dass es jetzt schon viel inhalt
gibt was die verschiedenen ländern nicht
durchsetzen
maly gab werden wieso aber heute genau
das ist nett das programm wurde ich
jetzt da um ihre bereitet hat er sehr
beschäftigt ist und dann eine dabei wird
amazonien nach ich bin so oder so da ist
und da ich für mich ganz wichtig dass er
da wirklich mitzieht was ich setze ist
die vielfältigkeit weil das ist auch die
aufforderung für uns ist dass wir viel
von alles machen müssen innerhalb von
ein oder ein bisschen mehr als ein jahr
ganz genau dass das dass sich gleich
hier reflektiert er selber hat viel
erfolg mit der wohnungs ohne sie ich
will mich auf die zusammenarbeit
wirklich kommt kleine seit mittwoch
ich bin der neue ideen dazu lernen ich
bin der star jack und ich auch schon
gemacht heute mittag kann man da siehst
du willst dass das das machen dass noch
eine reise darunter sind das finde ich
super spannend aber auch gefördert
[Musik]
der jonas ist im monat ohne ich sie in
die familie in buenos aires im praktikum
[Musik]
morgen reporterin katrin und tochter
cellistin da an
[Musik]
es ist gutes spannendes billigkeit
andreas hinkel befreien
[Musik]
herbert ratz ist ja politisch ist okay
gracias
ja
also das wäre perfekt aber es ist schon
nicht gleich mächtig qualität einfach
nicht wie sonst üblich und genau das
passiert jedes baby die lenker und
beifahrer und der tx max friedrich
bisher stoßen
das ist eigentlich
der kreis ist
ja
[Musik]
der jonas macht sich gedanken wie 2b mit
frau und kind in fremde großstadt wird
[Musik]
also ist klar das ist nicht der nine to
five job und man muss auch bewusst dass
es um arbeit und die zukunft so hin und
wieder in alaska aber immer etwas
gemeinsam beschlossen und von dem man
muss besser bewusst sie
[Musik]
evonik hatte jonas schock und ein fix
fertig möbliert die wohnung dahin ist
kathrin und cellistin wohl fühle
das ist sehr wichtig wird kathrin ist
bayern beruflich nie richtig politik sie
mögliche ganzen tollen job nicht kann
aber mit daher umziehen
und es ist nicht ganz einfach zum fall
so zwangsläufig und darum hoffe ich dass
sie wirklich erfüllen die aufgabe finden
grund das gesicht kathrin da wirklich
viel aber das in der nächsten folge
junger diplomat
[Musik]